the elite as I see it are the people who
run the country the broad elite consists
of the people who are prominent in
Kansas City or Indianapolis or
individual cities they're the CEOs the
most important industries they're the
mayor the people on the TV stations etc
the narrow elite is are those people who
have effects on the nation's culture and
economics and politics that's a very
small group you're probably talking
about fewer than a hundred thousand
people altogether who have that kind of
power and that's what I see as the class
the broad elite and the narrow elite who
have drawn away from the rest of the
country and formed enclaves and cultures
of their own they eat different foods
they drink different alcoholic beverages
the upper class for example has a
disdain of extraordinary force about
domestic mass-market beer you will never
see Budweiser in the refrigerator of a
member of the new upper class they raise
their children differently they go to
different churches they have different
religious attitudes in general if they
have if they go to church at all in
almost every way they have folkways that
separate them from mainstream America
take television for example the average
television set in the United States of
America is on 35 hours a week that's
probably too much but the fact is the
people who are watching that television
get an exposure to a popular culture in
very large doses what does the new
upper-class watch on television Downton
Abbey Mad Men the more adventurous
probably watch Breaking Bad but aside
from that they don't really watch TV and
in fact a lot of them will say to you
gee we don't even really have a TV
anymore
okay that's fine I'm not saying there's
something virtuous about watching TV 35
hours a week I am saying that when you
have that kind of divergence in that
single behavior you have part of the
reason that you have
and ignorant of and oftentimes a disdain
of mainstream America by the new upper
class which is very problematic in terms
of the future of the country one of the
things in the book that really worked
was my bubble quiz you know I faced the
problem of my audience really is
upper-middle class and upper class
people especially young people and I
wanted to to convince them of the degree
to which they are isolated in many cases
and since a lot of times you can't bring
too much quantitative data to bear on
that I said well I'll let it prove them
to themselves so I have a 25 item quiz
in it and a high score means you are not
in an upper-middle class model and a low
score means you are so some questions
are the importance is very obvious have
you ever lived in a neighborhood in
which more than half of your neighbors
did not have college degrees for example
some of them are a little mischievous
have you ever stalked your refrigerator
with mass-market American beer since the
signature of one of the signatures in
the new upper class is that all their
beers are handcrafted small batch
boutique beers other questions to me are
really significant into what they say
about the larger aspect of a person's
life for example have you ever walked in
a factory floor not necessarily have you
worked in the factory floor have you
ever seen a factory floor close-up
remembering for a moment that all of
these wonderful objects that fill your
lives were made almost all of them on
factory floors if I had to pick out the
one question I think is the most
important of all it is this have you
ever held a job that caused a body part
to hurt at the end of the day it's okay
if you just have feet that ache because
you've been standing on your feet all
day that counts too but if you have
never held such a job you are
intrinsically inherently in
to blee unable to understand the lives
of a great many of your fellow
countrymen who do hold such jobs I hope
that the the quiz uh has had a salutary
effect on bringing to people's attention
the degree to which they live in a
bubble that seals them off from an awful
lot of their fellow American citizens